foreign
people we are live on the computer
machine I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report and welcome to another
Friday Round Table Extravaganza before I
introduce my guests today this just
arrived in the mail and I wanted to call
attention to it this is a little statue
from the fine people over at Rumble it's
got It's got a decent amount of heft on
this thing this is to commemorate 250
000 subscribers on Rumble which we hit
like two weeks ago but as of today like
within the next few minutes if you
people do what I need you to do we will
cross 400 000 today so as you know we've
been talking about a lot lately Rumble
and the alternative pipes are blowing up
and that is at least part of what is
going to save us from this digital
dystopia that we happen to be in and I
think we'll talk a bit about that with
today's guests joining me today is the
CEO of Florida's voice Brendan Leslie
and the host of news and why it matters
on Blaze TV Sarah Gonzalez Brendan Sarah
welcome to the Reuben report thanks for
having us I appreciate it Dave I'm
excited Brandon you are a Reuben report
rookie so I will give you 30 seconds to
tell people about Florida's voice what
you're doing you're you're an actual
journalist I can actually say that
without uh putting air quotes around it
I know it's it's actually weird to see
these days I worked in TV news I worked
in the corporate media and it sucked it
really is fake news so I quit and I said
watch me do my own thing better uh and
we built our own thing in Florida's
voice and we're just reporting
everything that the mainstream media
doesn't and our motto over at Florida's
voice is to redefine the mainstream
media so that's what we're doing here in
Florida
and on a personal note everyone knows
how much I love Southwest Florida which
of course is where hurricane Ian hit and
you did unbelievable work throughout
that to help the people of Fort Myers
and Naples and the whole area uh so
happy to have you here and Sarah every
Rubin report viewer knows you already is
there anything you'd like to say before
we begin
uh I'm happy to be here I'm always it's
always an honor to be here with you Dave
um I I just like to remind everyone I am
creating uh or participating in the
parallel economy with my makeup company
you see I'm wearing a nice red lip it's
called huge lips and you can find it
over at americanbeauty by sarah.com wow
can I get some of that lip stuff you're
allowed to I mean we do cater to women
and we are proud to be women and we want
to empower women but I mean if you want
something but what is a woman really you
know right right but actually
so anyone can buy it exactly and we are
going to be uh talking about
International women's day which mostly
is guy with a penis and a dress day so
we'll get to all of that in just a
second uh but let's start with the
Divide between the blue and red States
it's obviously a big theme around here
and everyone's sort of talking about
just this this continued sort of
distancing between what's going on if
you live in a democrat-run state and you
live in a republican-run state uh and
Cali in Florida seem to be the two best
examples of that we've got some info
here on what's going on in California
right now this is from theblaze.com
Democrat Governor Gavin Newsom
forcefully criticized Walgreens over its
new plan to stop shipping and selling
abortion pills in some in some states
after 20 state attorney generals sent a
letter warning about the policy
Walgreens made the announcement on
Friday that it stores in 20 States would
not sell abortion pills we intend to be
a certified Pharmacy and we'll
distribute uh the fat pistrone only in
the jurisdictions where it is legal and
operationally feasible read a statement
from the company pro-abortion Advocates
said they would boycott the company over
the decision while pro-life Advocates
praised the decision Newsom issued a
fiery tweet on Monday excoriating the
company for caving to the demands from
20 state attorneys California won't be
doing business with Walgreens or any
company that cowers to the extremists
and puts women's lives at risk we're
done now first off it's a little unclear
to me if Gavin Newsom knows what those
pills actually do because some of those
babies do turn out to be women but again
what is a woman
my personal take on this it's like if
the if the states don't want the
abortion pills there and Walgreens wants
to abide by that that's fine Walgreens
isn't stopping anything from happening
in Cali but this is kind of what Newsome
does isn't it Sarah
yeah you know it's interesting because
in that statement that he gave he calls
Walgreens he says that they're
capitulating to extremists they're
following the law so I mean I I would
say the extremist is the one who is
demanding that a private company not
follow the law break the law in other
states in which Newsom has no pardon
just so that he can say uh hey we're
doing something we're helping women and
so it's just fascinating to see him you
know change use the the language to just
change the entire narrative I don't
think it's going to work and by the way
I would like to just bring up on the
issue of this abortion pill which is
what he's advocating that they allow by
mail this is a really dangerous thing I
mean you've got multiple studies that
show uh that there that they women are
more at risk for severe side effects
they've got hemorrhaging they're more at
risk for the need for follow-up surgery
uh even death and so by making this more
available to women by mail rather than
under a doctor's care he's saying that
this is about women but if he wanted it
to be about women why would he put them
more at risk I mean it just it blows my
mind that he's able to use this
narrative that Walgreens is the one
that's doing something wrong here right
and again he's just or Walgreens is just
going by what the state decisions are
this is not going to they're following
the law tally will still have their
eight and a half month abortions and
have their abortion parties and they can
bus in women from Texas usually young
black women and they can then have their
abortions and they combust them out
Optics on that may start looking bad
after a while uh Brandon I take it
you're not surprised by Gavin Newsom
having the wrong take on something I
mean it doesn't need to make sense with
the Democrats to to Sarah's point there
he's holding them accountable for
following the laws and you know what
laws are different in different states
and that's the Beautiful the beautiful
part about our constitutional republic
but I mean what governor Newsom is doing
is taking a stance nationally because
you know what he's probably next up for
for running for president for the
Democrats and it might happen as soon as
2024 so the Democrats think abortion is
a winning issue for them they think that
that's something that they can shove
down the into the face is of the right
and something that they can win down
ballot on but you know what I got a
surprise for them when they when you
look at polls abortion isn't even a top
five issue for voters they're you know
they're looking for economy gas prices
stuff like that so this is him just
taking a stance a ridiculous stance
because Governor Ron DeSantis who he
views as his number one adversary is
taking the opposite stance of him so
it's ridiculous that a private company
has to suffer because of just total
nonsense well speaking of Governor
Rhonda said this he went to Cali earlier
in the week and uh here's a little bit
from the Reagan Library
[Applause]
I know you guys got a lot of problems
out here but your Governor's very
concerned about what we're doing in
Florida so I figured I had to come by
Brendan you know a lot about Insider
Florida politics I mean he's in Iowa
right now is there something that
everyone should know that you know that
I don't even know
well it sure does seem that way now
doesn't it um
like I've been saying from the beginning
it's not 100 yet but it's pretty damn
close to being 100 of him running
um and this book tour I mean listen at
the end of the day it's a great thing
for the country to hear from Governor
Ron desant to see what Florida did the
Florida Republican party just it stands
out compared to the GOP nationally and
it stands out compared to just about
every single state GOP in this nation so
every 40 and all the 49 other states
need to be following the blueprint of
Florida and if they do we might see a
lot more Republican wins I mean remember
Florida was like a purple State not even
two years ago now it's a deep red State
and it has a lot to do with Governor Ron
desantis's leadership in conjunction
with all the teamwork that we're seeing
from the Republican party of Florida
yeah and by the way you're allowed to
say gay here they haven't banned any
books although they've taken about three
pornographic books out of uh elementary
schools but that's it and then there are
some other books under review and you
wouldn't put Mein Kampf in a fourth
grade class either Sarah is the Florida
Cali thing the thing that we just need
to have at this point like is that the
fight that really it all boils down to
right now
I mean I think that it does it's a
really really good contrast of what
works and what doesn't and I think
DeSantis is very smart for writing this
book giving the blueprint and then
touring regardless of whether or not he
runs right
um whether or not he runs One Thing
Remains clear he has as Brendan pointed
out completely transformed Florida he
won his first election by less than a
percentage point and look at how much he
has done to a meth addict right right
literally socialist a Democratic
Socialist he ran as a Democratic
Socialist did he not yeah yeah
so so that Florida was that close that
close to handing their whole state over
to a Democratic Socialist and they
didn't and now clearly they're happy
with that decision so I think that it's
smart to do the contrast because over
here you have Rhonda Santos who was
completely transformed Florida into a
heavily I mean I would argue that you
guys are more red than we are here in
Texas everyone thinks that Texas is some
deep red State not anymore floronda
Santos has done what needs to be done
while Governor Abbott just sits around
so to have that contrast between Rhonda
santis doing what needs to be done in
Florida and Gavin Newsom who had a mass
Exodus of people I know I'm preaching to
the choir here Dave a mass Exodus of
people who left because he was so
tyrannical he almost got recalled you've
got crime just I mean insane amounts of
crime you've got the homeless crisis
you've got all of these problems in
California because of the Democrat
policies and because they're so
tyrannical it's so smart to to make that
contrast to show people this is what
happens when you go conservative this is
what happens when you go left and let
the people make that decision
devil's advocate here Brendan for a
second to close this one out uh to me
the best argument against DeSantis as a
Floridian is I care more about the
states at this point the Laboratories of
democracy are working the big thing
isn't working and it may be so corrupt
that even a guy like him can't fix it so
as I think you're a are you you're a
lifelong Floridian right
no I wish I'm actually a New Yorker you
can't tell you can't tell and I'm very
proud of that wow all right so you're a
refugee yourself but so as a Floridian
though that someone that's that's now
very ingrained in what's happening here
in Florida is that the best argument
against DeSantis running that we've got
we've got grade A stuff right here and
maybe we don't want to just send it
right through the grinder no it's a
terrible argument no offense but uh
Governor Ron DeSantis has done a great
job in Florida and Florida actually has
a deep bench of candidates that can take
up this mantle that Governor Ron
DeSantis has put together here in
Florida I mean Congressman Byron Donalds
is a potential Ashley Moody Wilton
Simpson the AG commissioner is plenty of
people that will continue that
conservative legislation uh let us that
governing moving forward and Floridians
you see it you see the federal impacts
here locally with gas prices egg prices
the supply chain just because we have a
great Governor doesn't mean we're not
feeling those impacts from the Babbling
buffoon we have in the white house right
now so I would argue that there really
is no argument Governor Ron DeSantis
should have a chance to become president
one day whether it's in 2024 2028 and
Floridians should be uh Embrace that
right although the hardcore Trump people
seem to want the Rhino globalist to wait
to 2028 then they'll be okay with him
but we shall see anyway let's move on uh
the big thing yesterday which obviously
hits very close to home around here were
these hearings at the Capitol about the
Twitter files and they had two actual
journalists that I don't have to put air
quotes around Matt taibi and Michael
schellenberger these guys are lefties
they are lifelong lefties taibi I would
say most of his life are far Lefty uh
shellenberger maybe a little more of a
moderate but no doubt these are not
Republicans these are not conservatives
anyway they got just attacked and
smeared by the Democrats during this
this absolute sham of a hearing take a
look at this uh here's a little battle
between Jim Jordan and this I did not
know this woman before this is Stacy
plasquette and she's going after the
sources the sources for these guys I
mean it's just incredible
did Mr musk contact you Mr taibi again
the attribution for my story is sources
of Twitter Mr schellenberger did Mr musk
contact you uh actually no I was brought
in by my friend Barry Weiss and so this
story there's been a lot of
misinformation
Ms Weiss thank you Mr taibi have you had
conversations with Elon Musk I have okay
uh Mr Tybee did Mr musk place any
conditions on the use of the gentle lady
yield for a second uh as long as my time
is not used are you trying to get
journalists no I'm not trying to do this
I'm not I am asking no and to praise him
for his work this isn't just a matter of
what data was given to these so-called
journalists before us now there are many
legitimate questions about where musk
got the financing to buy Twitter
my name is Matt taibi I've been a
reporter for 30 years and a staunch
advocate of the First Amendment much of
that time was spent at Rolling Stone
magazine ranking member Plaskett I'm not
a so-called journalist I've won the
national magazine award the ifstone
award for independent journalism and
I've written 10 books including four New
York Times New York Times bestsellers
I'm now the editor of the online
magazine racket on the independent
platform sub stack
I mean there's so much here it's
incredible first off she doesn't know
that Barry Weiss is a woman so she
doesn't know who Barry Weiss is I mean
to be at a hearing about the Twitter
files I mean Barry was one of the people
that have released one of the original
ones she's well known in these circles
so put that aside then she calls them
so-called journalists as taibi pointed
out they are not so-called journalists
they are actual journalists uh and the
fact that she's going after sources
which is the biggest No-No in journalism
which is almost dead but not completely
Sarah like just clown show 101 like what
what else can we say yeah I know and
there's there's there really is so much
to unpack there because uh it shows us
several different things at once number
one these people in Congress are
completely incompetent they have no idea
what they're doing they don't even come
to a hearing with the having done the
research on what in the world they're
going to talk about I mean you you also
uh later in that hearing that I think it
was representative so Sylvia Gonzalez
who was like well I have this here a sub
stack I don't know what what is a sub
stack I don't know what that is like
they don't even read any of this
beforehand they just come in with a
narrative to push because they believe
that they are the elites and we are not
and we are not allowed to know when they
are collaborating with a private company
to shut down speech we're not allowed to
know these things and so that's why
she's trying to discredit Matt taibi
she's calling him a so-called journalist
uh you know they don't think that we
should be allowed to know how far the
corruption goes
um and I just it's it's it's laughable
at this point that they think that
they're so far above us and and I think
that they're so arrogant they've gotten
so arrogant about having these
Partnerships with these private
companies because remember
we don't know what the hell's going on
at Facebook right we don't know what
conversations they're having with Mark
Zuckerberg and his team we only know
this because of Elon musk's takeover and
so I just I think that they've gotten so
arrogant in running this entire country
uh quietly through these private
companies that they just never they
never thought that all of this
information should be made public so now
that it is they wanna they wanna
intimidate journalists and they want to
they want them to know that we're going
to push you to to you know to tell us
your sources I mean you saw even Pete
Buda judge had the Daily Caller reporter
that was following him and he made sure
to say can I take a picture of you I
mean they are trying to intimidate
journalists into being scared of
reporting the truth I think that that's
very clear with this with this regime
now you know to your point on what we
don't know related to Facebook and
YouTube and everything else it's like it
obviously was happening at Facebook and
YouTube meeting government intervention
like there's simply well we know
Facebook for sure because saki admitted
it you know I think last summer so
there's no doubt it was happening at you
YouTube too but now because we haven't
done anything about it for months God
only knows what they've you know
digitally put through the the paper
Scrapper and everything else uh Brendan
is the is the white pill on all of this
like nobody believes them nobody watched
that I didn't see anyone online that
watched that that was like boy those
Dems they're doing a great job with this
thing
and I'm glad that that is the take
because honestly I look at this from a
First Amendment as a journalist
perspective what they're doing I'm
making a journalist testify about their
Story I mean that's just that's just the
gov that's big government bullying
private citizens into submission just
like what Sarah was saying that's
ridiculous and I saw that that that clip
with the Daily Caller reporter with gay
with gay mayor Pete um it just these
people don't want to accept actual
journalism in the hard questions and
then they go turn around and argue that
Governor Ron DeSantis or Donald Trump
are the fascists when these people are
bullion reporters left and right I mean
I had an instance we had Charlie Chris
when he was running for governor against
Ronda santis and then got his ass kicked
by 20 points uh he was soliciting
donations from Hurricane Ian victims
here in Fort Myers he was saying hey if
you're a hurricaneian victim tell me
your story and then when you go click on
the link it's like oh chipping five
dollars for my campaign and I was the
only journalist to ask that questions
and I take it personally because I was
I'm from Fort Myers so I go and meet up
with Charlie Chris at his event where he
was supposedly supposed to be handing
out supplies and he wasn't he was just
doing a photo up and I went up to him I
said hey Charlie like why are you
soliciting donations from Hurricane em
victims and the response was his goons
yeah they basically pushed yeah yeah
they were screaming and spitting in my
face as goon was like shoving me and
trying to get me away from Charlie
saying that I touched him but when you
go and watch the video I didn't even go
come anywhere near to touching him I
might have grazed his hand on accident
because he got into my personal space
but they lose their mind because they
can't answer the real question we see it
time and time again from every single
Democrat how many times did Sarah
embarrass Beto O'Rourke asking real
questions I mean they're just complete
it's all nonsense right or Sarah you've
been going to the to the drag shows in
Texas which the idea of a kids drag show
in Texas of all places like it's just
all so crazy but I want to show you one
other uh clip from the hearing because
Jim Jordan who I think has really become
an All-Star on this stuff like he really
is fighting the good fight right now
obviously congressman from Ohio uh he
got into it with congresswoman Plaskett
about what we're discussing right now
and it's a really great moment either
musk is the source and he can't talk
source if musk is not is not Source then
the ladies out of order you don't get to
see me
what he has said is he's not going to
reveal his source and the fact that
Democrats are pressuring him to do so
I do think it's worth pointing out that
you know I have a co-sponsor and I think
some of my colleagues have co-sponsored
the shield Act
in previous congresses with Democrats
to protect what we see them trying to do
today protect journalists from having to
reveal their sources to government
that used to be a shared position in the
Congress unfortunately as we're seeing
now multiple occasions it's not the it's
not the position anymore
Sarah is the issue here that the
Democrats at this point and I really I
try to be as Fair as I can but it seems
to me they have no rules there is no
rule that they will not break in the
quest for power so I don't think any of
those congresswomen there give a flying
F about what the rules are and what
journalistic Integrity is ETC
well you're right because it's not just
journalism it's like every facet of uh
the government and and the left really
they show you that they set a standard
in which they intend for you to live by
they don't care to live by that standard
and they don't care to live by those
rules that's why anytime there's a
Democrat who says something racist Joe
Biden says something racist they're like
well he didn't mean it that way you guys
are just misinterpreting it uh Donald
Trump says I ha you know here's my black
friend and they say he's the most racist
person ever I mean they don't they set
these standards these unlivable
standards and they never they never
intended to live by them and you know I
recall not too long ago back when there
was an orange man bad in the White House
they were complaining about uh you know
freedom of the press being threatened
freedom of the press was under assault
because Donald Trump wouldn't answer
their question Donald Trump wouldn't
allow one CNN reporter in his press
conference room even though others were
there and they accused him of assaulting
the first Amendment this is the type of
thing that you're talking about Dave to
go to your point they never they never
intended to live by these rules they're
just rules for you to live by yeah
here's one other little throwaway clip
here somehow the phrase threesome got
brought up at a congressional hearing
enjoy this friend works for Twitter or
what is what is her um she's a
journalist sir I didn't ask you a
question I'm now asking Mr
schellenberger a question yes ma'am
Barry White is a journalist I'm sorry
sir she's a journalist she's a
journalist or you work in concert with
her
um yeah
do you know when she first
um was contacted by Mr musk I I don't
know you don't know so you're in this as
a threesome
um there was many more people involved
in that there was many more people
involved with it
it was way better than a threesome guys
but the point again these people have no
idea who they're talking about the
issues that they're asking about and I
just want to mention one other thing
which is that when I went to San
Francisco into the Twitter offices and
met with Elon people know this already
but I met with the guy for a couple
hours I said to him at the end hey do
you mind if I repeat any of this and
without hesitation he said as long as
it's true so the idea that somehow he
was manipulating all these people he had
no idea who I sat with for hours the
engineers before meeting him he said as
long as it's true that's all you really
need to know about that but let's move
on because it is international women's
week so obviously Brendan I'm gonna have
to throw to you first uh Hillary Clinton
chimed in on what's going on with the
chicks these days and uh here's a doozy
for you
finally I'm so glad that
Elena zelenska is here because women are
women and and children are the primary
victims of conflict and of climate
change and there is no place that
unfortunately tragically shows us that
more dramatically than Ukraine today
it's so incredibly stupid that words
actually Escape me women climate is
coming for women conflicts coming from
it seems like usually it's an awful lot
of men out there doing the fighting but
Brendan as a woman this is a very
exciting month for you what do you make
of Hillary the war in Ukraine is mostly
about women women have penises
Etc
I I you know I'm curious of her comments
they say that uh the climate's coming
for women more than men I I don't know I
feel like men are a little bit heavier
and they have tend to have more uh
muscle on their body you know just basic
science so that means we sweat a little
bit more when it gets when it gets
hotter out so I take a fence to that I
also saw a great meme just right before
I came on it was like International
women's day was yesterday but it's
actually today because women took too
long to get ready ah there you go there
you go it's
it's didn't some crazy trans person
trans woman win an international well
we'll get to that we'll get to that I'm
sorry I'm jumping the gun you're jumping
ahead Sarah just this endless nonsense
like linking these things somehow
climate change has something to do with
Ukraine and that really has something to
do with women how do they do it the
magic trick right in front of us I'm
convinced Dave that they have uh they
have like a chart and on the chart they
have the buzzwords so they have uh the
special interest groups they have women
they have minorities so they have black
people they have Hispanics they have the
lgbtqia plus however many acronyms they
have now and they have all of the all of
the categories and then they have issues
so they have climate change they have
War they have the economy they have all
of these issues and they just pick on
one day whatever day it is they go you
know what I'm going women and climate
change and they just link everything
that they're talking about to those two
things I'm convinced of it because
that's the only thing that makes sense
that doesn't make sense mind you but
it's the only thing that makes the most
sense nothing else makes sense on this
all right let's get let's get to the
clip let's get to the clip that Brendan
mentioned so because it is international
women's month everybody gets a month and
even though we can't decide what a woman
is uh Jill Biden Dr Jill Biden and
Secretary of State Anthony blinken were
giving out some International women
Awards and uh yeah one of them included
giving an award to a dude enjoy in
Argentina Alba ruata is a transgender
woman who was kicked out of classrooms
barred for sitting for exams refused job
opportunities subjected to violence and
rejected by her family but in the face
of these challenges she worked to end
violence and discrimination against the
lgbtqi plus community and Argentina
you could see that Lincoln wanted to go
for tongue there couldn't you Brendan he
was definitely making the move
well what better way to accept this
thing as a woman than for blinken to
just go full on tongue make out with it
uh it's so we're literally fighting with
the devil this is what what is happening
in society and it's so infuriating
because how long how long did women
fight to just get a you know an evening
playing field for years and then when
they finally get it
in comes the Democrats with a wrecking
ball like Miley Cyrus just ruining it
and just destroying everything that it
is about being a woman you know what's
interesting I I feel like we never talk
about trans men it's always trans women
that is a thing so that that's very
curious to me and it's it's such a slap
in the face I really I I really hope I
become a dad one day but I really hope
it's not to a girl because I don't know
how I'm gonna explain all this craziness
to her one day it's just so sad
well you know joking aside for just a
second my personal take on this is I
don't care how someone chooses to live
once they are an adult but when we are
pushing this stuff on kids it's a
different thing and to your point we are
giving awards to biological men in the
name of women so it's an assault on
women and I would say the trans thing is
also an assault on gay people because
they've because gay the gay rights
movement was always about equality and
now it's being replaced with oh you
better literally chop your genitals off
and become the opposite sex because
somehow that's more tolerable than
actually being gay Sarah you you've done
a lot with the the trans situation
because of the drag queen shows in Texas
so I'll just kind of throw it to you
there and go whichever way you want to
go well
I mean I have a couple things to to say
here you know it's fascinating that for
all this time the left wanted to talk
about the patriarchy the patriarchy the
patriarchy is taking things from women
can you think of more representative
example of the patriarchy than men
literally replacing Us in everything
it's maddening all these feminists that
are like yay I'm so happy that men are
replacing us and taking our Awards and
our scholarships and they're invading
our bathrooms they are literally a this
is the Erasure of women and I don't
understand the radical feminist who as
Brendan pointed out fought for so long
to to you know for what they called
equality just to sit back and watch all
of these men take over they think that
you know slapping on a bunch of makeup
and putting on some fake breasts is
going to make them a woman I just it's
so maddening to me because Womanhood I
mean we are uniquely made we we are our
bodies are so unique I I talked about
this yesterday on my program I can grow
human life right and then I can burn
those babies my organs shift in my body
they know exactly where to shift so that
my womb can expand and after I deliver
the baby my organs know how to shift
back my body knows how to produce milk
for my babies that give my babies just
the right nutrients that they need these
are all unique traits about women and
these men will never be that and it's
just so frustrating to see people cheer
along like they like they don't
understand that it's like no one is Will
no one on the left is willing to say
we know we like we know this they know
this they all know this but they're too
scared of being called transphobic or
whatever phobic that they just sit here
and cheer it along I gotta tell you it's
getting pretty scary out here as Brendan
mentioned you know he said he didn't
want to have a girl I'm hopeful that by
the time you know maybe in in five years
or so hopefully we can right this ship
because it's gotten so absurd I mean
this is just absurdity playing out in
real life you look at all these South
Park clips and all of these you know
Simpsons clips clips that are
resurfacing from like 2004 where it was
meant as a joke because it was something
that was so outlandish that nobody
thought that it would ever happen and
now it's real life so I'm hopeful
especially with all of the drag stuff
that I'm doing as well I'm seeing the
pendulum swing back because people are
going
oh that's really happening yeah we we've
we've gone too far this is too far yeah
and I think the other important piece of
this that apparently the lefties don't
seem to understand is that you can
actually be accepting or acknowledge
someone else's existence you don't have
to celebrate everything about everyone
it doesn't mean you should be jailing
people but you don't have to celebrate
everything and the left seems to have
this need to celebrate absolutely
everything which usually is a dance on
the bodies of women or other minorities
or whatever but let's move to one other
thing because we are rolling into this
2024 situation this thing never ends and
there are some legitimate questions I
would say about the mental acuity of Joe
Biden so Dr Jill we've got another Dr
Jill clip uh Dr Jill who Whoopi Goldberg
said should be the Surgeon General which
is
um she was asked about Joe Biden's
mental Fitness and this answer is just
incredible
Nikki Haley one of the Republican
candidates is calling for mental
competency tests for those politicians
over the age of 75. what do you think
about that ridiculous
would your husband ever take one of
those
I mean we haven't even discussed we
would never even discuss something like
that
we would never discuss something like
that let's put aside 2024 or Joe Biden
being president if you let's say Sarah
I'll go to you first on this one if you
were married uh you know you're married
now but I mean when you're 75 and you
and your husband have been married for
50 some odd years if you notice that he
was forgetting things constantly often
seem to not know where he was was
slurring words couldn't remember things
would give up in the middle of sentences
putting aside what his job was if he
wasn't retired at that point would you
maybe discuss going to the doctor with
him would that be some or would that
just be a dick move
yeah I mean I would say the dick move is
uh the elder abuse that Jill Biden is
committing right now by not doing that I
mean she pushed her husband into this
she was constantly trying to you know
make excuses for him and uh like tell
reporters not to ask questions uh you
know get in between the mix because she
was trying to cover the fact that he is
incapacitated as we all can see because
we all have ears and eyes and we can see
it so I mean I guess like she wouldn't
discuss it with him because she knows
that his brain is already pudding and
the dementia has already set in and
there's no point in discussing it
because if she did discuss it she would
have to reveal that she's known this for
a very long time and pushed him into it
anyway which is not what a good spouse
would do obviously but it's really
interesting to me that the mainstream
media who carried water for this guy
they let him campaign from his basement
they asked him softball questions I mean
they helped him into this and now all of
a sudden they want to turn around and be
like oh well we didn't know how could we
have known that this guy is so you know
like he can't remember anything and as
you mentioned he's slurring his words
he's dripping up the stairs his son is a
crackhead like how could we have
possibly known any of these things it's
just it's fascinating to watch the
mainstream media now start to turn on
him now start to ask these tough
questions that I don't think that the
bidens were prepared for well what's so
also interesting is like there's such an
easy way to end this immediately which
would be somebody with balls maybe Peter
Ducey because he seems like he's the
only one at the at the press conferences
to just flat out say hey Korean yes or
no is the president on medication for
his memory yes or no don't ask don't ask
it in any kind of other ancillary fancy
way yes or no and she'll say she doesn't
know and refer you to the doctor but
that would at least start it because
he's obviously on something when they
get him out of debate he obviously has
taken something he's sometimes very
cogent and sometimes not it's a sad
reality he's the pilot of the plane I
wish he knew how to fly so whether I
like where where we're going or not with
this guy Brendan doesn't surprise you
right I mean she's she's Run cover as
Sarah said oh absolutely and what
infuriates me even more is one time
Donald Trump held a glass of water yeah
and the media was out for his head and
saying he needed to take a mental uh
test of some sort and now we're not
going to do it with Joe Biden and like
Sarah said they were carrying the water
for him
um I think the the corporate media and
the Democrats are in cahoots they're
working together we know that for it's
happening so I think everyone thought
that things would go a little bit better
than what is happening right now under a
first term President Biden it's been
just a complete catastrophe everywhere
you go it's horrible I mean you couldn't
even you couldn't even predict it to be
this bad so because of that now you
start seeing the sprinkle of those hard
questions because maybe just maybe there
is some sort of plan to get Biden out
and Gavin Newsom in for the 2024
election because let me tell you if a
guy like Ron DeSantis is on the bait
page with
Joe Biden for a debate in the 2024
election
Ron's gonna run away with it in a
landslide and they know that they do
know that that's why everyone's coming
after Ron DeSantis these days because
they view his as a threat so maybe
they're gonna start sprinkling in the
questions and then they might get a
little bit harder and harder and harder
and more often the closer we get and
we'll see what happens but it sure seems
like Gavin Newsom is considering a 2024
run well if it isn't Joe Biden and it
isn't Kevin Newsom it might just be the
crystal lady because Marianne Williamson
everyone remembers her she's back in
she's gonna run and check out a little
bit of this interview she's asked why
she wants to be are we not going to play
this clip
I'm being told we are not going to play
this oh no can I say something really
yeah say something about it all right I
think I think something happened here
the clip might have got corrupt or
something so go ahead Sarah okay well so
I mean you're talking about you know
Gavin Newsom or uh Marianne Williamson
or whoever it may be the question for me
is how do you gracefully get rid of not
just Joe but you guys Kamala is over
there she's already VP you guys have
already heralded her as like the first
woman the first Indonesian the first you
know all of these boxes Kwanzaa
celebrator don't forget she celebrated
Kwanzaa how do you gracefully dump Joe
and Kamala and replace what Kamala you
would assume Kamala would be the next in
line and replace her with a white man
how do you gracefully do that what are
the Optics of that when you're the
Democrats I don't I don't know how they
get there well Sarah Democrat privilege
is getting away with everything Brendan
go ahead yeah I was gonna say I mean
look the media convinced us that Joe
Biden was the next Messiah right I mean
they can easily convince that Gavin
Newsom is much better than Kamala Harris
they can't have her run they know that's
just that's horrible and she's just
gonna go away quietly I guess literally
I mean the people that are watching this
stuff they believe them and they believe
that that Joe Biden was the best option
for president they'll believe him that
Gavin Newsom is the next guy I'm not too
worried about that well you guys like us
that that don't buy it you're in luck
because we have uncorrupted the file to
show you another great thinker here's
Marianne Williamson
why do you want to be president I want
to be president because this country
needs to make an economic U-turn and the
system that effectuates and perpetuates
that kind of income and opportunity
inequality is not changing itself it
tweaks itself every once in a while
there's some incremental change but the
devastation the ubiquitous economic
Despair and human Devastation that is
produced by this sociopathic economic
system is not changing and it's not
going to change if we continue to elect
the same also
all right first off I just want to say
that someone that's interviewed her her
accent is totally fake and she puts that
on when she's doing interviews and it's
gotten much more it's gotten much more
drastic than it was two years ago I I do
have to make note that when I
interviewed her two years ago and I had
a bunch of Democrats on and I treated
them exactly the way I treat all of my
guests I'd Yang on I had tulsion I was a
Democrat at the time Marion Williamson
the second the camera went off
she told me that she thinks that the
base of the left are race are are awful
and evil and mean and that she never
gets hate like that from the right and
she then said to me that she's mostly a
Libertarian she would never say that on
camera she got caught once saying that
on camera when she went on Eric
bowling's show I think on Newsmax a
couple years ago so the woman is a
complete fraud and what is with
Democrats and fake accents what is that
Sarah
uh I mean well they they don't have any
principles Dave they don't so they have
sauce yeah exactly that's what I'm
saying they shape-shift into whatever
they think that will get them the you
know buy them the most votes buy them
the most likes so they're just
constantly shaping themselves you
mentioned the hot sauce uh you know
you've also got like Kamala Harris
putting on some fake accent when she
goes and and talks in front of uh black
people you've got AOC who does the same
thing whenever she's in New York and she
wants to act like she's Jenny from the
Bronx and so they just they don't have
any real Prince identity and so they
they just have to constantly shape-shift
into who they're in front of
Brendan I think it's Jenny From the
Block is the Block in the Bronx though
she's Jenny From the Block but I think
the block is probably in the Bronx right
yeah I would imagine bronx-ish okay it
reminds me of the time fun fact way back
when an opponent and I hosted their
first debate and I was the I was the
moderator for it
Cindy yeah Byron's is very well spoken
man he's a black conservative he's from
Brooklyn he's had trouble with the law
but he's really turned into a great
thing and taking a second chance taking
advantage of his second opportunity
Cindy during the debate
it was like she was straight from the
hood Straight From the Block
she I was like it was so painful because
she doesn't talk like that and we're all
just we're all looking at each other
while this debate is going on for an
hour she was keeping up this accident I
was like what are you doing they're just
pandering because like Sarah said zero
principles I mean Joe Biden he went to a
black college a Puerto Rican College a
Somalian College I lost track of how
many different colleges yeah yeah he
grew up going to Temple he also went to
the mosque he was in the Puerto Rican
Day Parade he's yeah this guy's been
everywhere it's a miracle the guy can't
remember a thing and yet he has every uh
every event that he's ever been to he
can remember just like that yeah this
fake also her fake accent because her
fake accent sounds like an elite accent
but she's also telling you that
capitalism is awful she's of course
worth a couple million bucks and yada
yada oh anyway guys I have thoroughly
enjoyed this show Sarah you're always
welcome back Brendan I will have to talk
to the team but I think you've passed
we'll link to your stuff down below I'm
gonna finish up with the post game show
in about uh 51 seconds so if you want to
join us for that and throw in some
questions and comments and if we made
any factual errors I will gladly correct
them uh join us in just a couple seconds
at reubenreport.locals.com and everyone
else have a great weekend and I'll see
you on Monday
[Music]
thank you